E aí
[Música]
o Olá o meu nome é Catarina
Eu sou estudante de medicina hoje vem
pagar os sobre acessibilidade e o que
todos podemos fazer para quebrar algumas
Barreiras
e eu não sou todo foram tem língua
gestual portuguesa
Oi mas como é que vocês se sentiram
neste juntos
e conseguiram entender aquilo que os
tentei dizer
e eu penso que vocês todos conseguiram
perceber mensagem porque mesmo para
aqueles que não entendem a língua
gestual Portuguesa e até mesmo para
aqueles que não conseguimos escutar o
áudio tão baixinho tiveram uma coisa que
Deus lhe dê sempre as legendas mas já
aqui voltamos primeiro quero perguntar
se imaginam e sabem como será viver com
alguma incapacidade
eu disse que levantassem a mão todos
aqueles que vivem com alguma
incapacidade ou clicam de perto com
alguém nessa condição Eu estou Segura
que quase toda a gente levantaria a mão
e não é difícil da nossa mente não
termos automaticamente para os nossos
sabores o meu avô por exemplo no auge
dos seus 90 anos tem um sentido de humor
brutal mas para que me veja a frente
tenho que fechar um olho para medir
segurança senhas e vou ganhar um outro
pelo meio conta umas andanças e às vezes
eu fico mesmo confusão Será que ele está
a ver assim tão mau ou será que está só
a tentar retornar a situação engraçada
é mas não é preciso irmos tão longe na
escala da idade
e quando vocês já tiveram de usar gesso
é lembram-se daqueles 15 dias em que as
vossas melhores amigas foram as cada
deles lembram-se to com difícil depois
subir a escadaria daquele prédio só
porque não tinha elevador
e eu tenho certeza que também se lembram
daquela sensação de alívio e pensarem em
gratidão por aquilo ser temporário e por
em 15 dias você já conseguirem correr
E isto é o que acontece quando somos
confrontados com alguma Barreiro nós
temos consciência do que é viver com
elas e do que é viver sem elas estão
descemos mais empatia para os que vivem
assim diariamente
se existe alguma coisa muito estranha
descansar porque é que nós somos mais
empáticos apenas quando nós estamos mais
vulneráveis no final 2019 eu fui
diagnosticada com surdez neurossensorial
bilateral moderado para os simplificar
eu tenho audição de um jovem 70 anos que
ele bastante mal mas apesar de só ter
sido diagnosticada recentemente eu
sempre escutei muito mal em miúda não
responde aos meus pais
tô numa consulta no médico eu garanti os
meus pais que eu tinha uma audição
perfeitamente normal que devia ser só
uma rapariga traquinas e desatenta
E aí não acredito não havia grande coisa
a fazer a não ser vida como sempre tinha
vivido e como sabia eu aprendi ajudado
confortável com desconfortável
e hoje em dia eu agradeço este erro
porque eu tenho certeza que se
tivéssemos ficado naquela altura eu
queria sim criada e teria crescido numa
Redonda talvez até não tivesse estudado
música por mais de dez anos talvez até
não tivesse tido a Brilhante ideia de me
candidatar ao ensino superior em canto
lírico Vocês conseguem imaginar
e o pacto de eu não ter um diagnóstico
precisamente permitimos viver e não ter
passado por todas as minhas limitações
sem sentir diferente
e quer dizer menos para jogar no
telefone estragado eu não sei se vocês
lembram desse jogo mas quando esse era o
jogo escolhido do dia eu ficava
realmente nervosa e eu era aquela vossa
amiga que se estragavam sempre sempre
sempre o jogo
a receber este nóstico no entanto serviu
apenas para dar um nome as inquietações
que eu senti a minha vida toda serviu
para esclarecer as coisas passei por
alguma fase de transição adaptaram esta
Nova Condição apesar de não ser tão nova
e dentro com outros objetivos como usar
a minha voz para o que mais importa
a semente eu coloquei os meus aparelhos
auditivos e a minha vida mudou quando
mais um seja porque as 25 anos que eu a
primeira vez eu conseguia ouvir
passarinhos a cantar
e com isto percebi também o porquê de eu
nunca ter achado piada a estes animais
Sem dúvida que as minhas próteses são
mais valia para mim e para todas as que
usam Mas elas de todo não subirem as
nossas limitações podemos de fatos as
estatísticas da Organização Mundial de
Saúde são bastante Claras atualmente
mais de 1,5 milhões de pessoas no mundo
que vive como verdade audição esta
ligeira a profunda falamos de uma em
cada cinco pessoas
É eu sei que é visualmente passa na
identificarmos um surdo porque eu único
numa língua a língua já estão portuguesa
e é também visualmente fácil
identificarmos uma pessoa que tenha
problemas de visão habitualmente elas
usam óculos importante nós estamos
automaticamente mais respectivos essa
condição nós enquanto seres humanos
estamos automaticamente mais simpáticos
para com aquela pessoa porque estamos em
Alerta
Tá mas e todos os que sofrem de perda de
audição
E porque é que nos passam despercebidas
porque é que são tão invisíveis a
verdade é que a probabilidade de alguém
que esteja aqui a ouvir esta conversa de
ter perda de audição é bastante grande é
com vestido somos um em cada cinco é
também importante vocês vão e sem as
vossas queixas que passam chegamos
regularmente sentirem que ela não está
certo eu posso dar o exemplo de uma
amiga minha que há coisa de dois meses
quando se encontrava a minha situação e
a minha história me disse que realmente
eu sempre houve um bocado mal mas eu
nunca fiz exames
e resultou desses exames Ela descobriu
que tinha um problema e possivelmente
também ela terá que usar próteses
e foi algo conta que está cada vez mais
com a comunidade surda que me apercebi
que estão um tema quente sabe ser falado
e discutido é necessário informar e
atendem que eu falo uma posição muito
privilegiada porque eu consigo ouvir
como ajuda Isto é eu consigo ter uma
vida diária normal e facilitada com a
ajuda das minhas próteses mas eu juntos
estaremos nós a comportar-nos como uma
sociedade inclusiva incomodam continuar
as barreiras que eu vejo diariamente a
serem impostas a comunidade surda em
Portugal
a falta de adaptação nós existimos em
deixar passar a contribui apenas mas
para a exclusão destes cidadãos que têm
direitos iguais aos cidadãos ouvintes
e a muita coisa que nós podemos fazer
juntos para quebrar estas barreiras e
lutar por uma maior inclusão
Tá bom então falarmos um pouco sobre
acessibilidade
e vocês já imaginaram que parte um sub
Tenho de ir uma consulta médica
se não puder fazer-se acompanhar por um
familiar Ou até mesmo que não queiram
ele terá que pagar do próprio bolso um
de língua gestual portuguesa talvez este
tenha sido o exemplo mais gritante como
surgiu por causa da minha informação
Isto é impensável mas é realidade um
momento tão pessoal como uma consulta
médica mas falamos de outros momentos
também acessórios como por exemplo ir às
Finanças ou a Segurança Social estamos a
falar da Independência destes cidadãos
que aposta em causam português de
serviços públicos número da arrisco-me a
dizer ou quase nunca acesso a
atendimento personalizado em língua
gestual portuguesa
e não conteste mais atual como este da
pandemia uso obrigatório de máscaras e
distanciamento social só veio aumentar
as dificuldades de comunicação não só
para os que têm perda de audição mas
foram para os próprios todos eles
comunicam em língua gestual gestos
pensão aos seres mas não são só os
gestos estamos a falar de expressões
faciais estamos a falar de padrões
labiais que estão a ser barrados porque
ela por causa do uso da máscara
o botão sim é necessário consigamos
trabalhar mais um sentido de optimizar
recursos para ter as máscaras sociais
transparente certificadas sejam mais do
que uma boa ideia que sejam também uma
realidade
o que o custo de produção EA própria
hipertensão delas seja igual ou
semelhante acho que nós usamos mais
frequentemente
e falemos do cultura também
é uma visita a um museu vocês podem
sempre justificar-se com o típico de
eles também podem ler as descrições dos
quadros Às vezes sim mas eu digo estão
bem já pensamos nisto há muitos anos
atrás em audioguias porque não avisei o
dias porque não vire as guias que
permitam um suco de ter uma visita
realmente inclusiva e mês Iva em cada
Museu o
e deixa-me dizemos que este trabalho já
está a ser realizada em nos países baixo
por mim empresa criada por duas irmãs
surdas
eu sou a televisão eu posso dar o meu
exemplo só eu sempre fui aquela rapariga
que não ligava a desenhos animados
e para impressionantes meus pais e dos
meus vizinhos eu vou tentar localizam no
máximo e tentava perceber o que se
estava a passar mas eu rapidamente
perdeu o interesse
e o esforço que eu tinha de fazer para
um momento de lazer ver televisão é
demasiado hoje em dia claro que esta
falha pode ser com uma tarde porque as
crianças já têm acesso à internet e
conseguem receber muito mais fácil de
mim a conteúdos adaptados para si Mas
por que não interessantes ou até mesmo
legendar eu lembro que muitas das minhas
tardes de verão a ver Morangos com
Açúcar eram salvos pelas Legendas do
teletexto
é mas ainda sou da televisão numa
perspectiva mais informativa todos nós
Já paramos nos que os internos língua
gestual portuguesa estão alojados no
retão muito pequenina na televisão
é mas somos lançar um desafio reproduzir
em um único gesto que seja Será que
vocês conseguem quase que tenham
semicerrar os olhos para entender o que
se está a passar naquele retângulo certo
é porque não então aumentarmos e
permitimos que a mensagem seja o passada
a quem precisa efetivamente de eu ver
e isto Pode não ter parecido muitas
queixas e muita informação mas na
verdade São apenas pequenas mudanças que
nós podemos fazer com que realmente
pouco esforço que pode quebrar barreiras
e para a lente de Braga Reis vai criar
pontos vai estabelecer o maior ligação
entre as pessoas acesso e inclusão a
e eu perguntas Quem vai levar isto
e eu acredito que somos todos nós todos
nós podemos fazer a nossa parte em fazer
do mundo um local mais inclusive um
mundo com menos Barreiras em que haja
acessibilidade para todos e que essa
acessibilidade seja Independente de
qualquer condição médica
o homem que nós vamos mudar isto
e por Passos pequenos vamos começar por
Passos pequenos e o primeiro passo é
esse que ele estava aqui hoje
sensibilização educação
é uma pessoa comum capacidade é um
cidadão com deveres e direitos iguais a
todos os A única diferença para ti que
me estás a ouvir é que estes cidadãos
muitas vezes faz bem nos seus direitos
reduzidos
e o que pode começar fazer desde já hoje
estar consciente Esta é a realidade de
muita gente
a começar receber um pouco do que é ser
diferente
e tem que ser mais calmo mais
compreensivo para sentir de empatia
precisa estar consciente de que te
rodeia as nossas diferenças são as
nossas forças
E isto é poderosa em uma grossa a
solução para nos unir em entender estas
diferenças
a empatia é uma coisa muito simples e no
entanto tão complicada
é mas a boa notícia no meio disto tudo é
que se puder está em todos nós
[Aplausos]